old or chosen by God to be the people
through whom all nations would be
blessed Israel was chosen to bless
others
in the Christian scriptures the same
language is used to describe the church
which is why William Temple a former
Archbishop of Canterbury could say that
the church is the only organization that
exists solely for the benefit of its
non-members
well I love that quote however I am sure
the same could be said of this place
surely the existence of Trafford council
is to benefit those who are not sitting
here this evening
you are here not to be served but to
serve
in the Bible the word used to describe
God's choice of Israel and the church to
be those who bless others through active
service is election
well we've just had one of those and the
people of Trafford have chosen you to be
those who they believe will serve the
common good
so may I encourage you to live up to
your election
and follow the example of our king and
the one whom he seeks to follow
so once again I offer you all my
congratulations on all your hard work to
get here
now the real work begins amen
thank you Richard for those very wise
words
apologies for absence have been received
from councilors Jed Carter and
accordingly uh can I ask if anyone is
aware of any other apologies
Jill Oxford Jill Oxford
sorry counselor broken was that correct
yeah
um someone behind you was that the same
apology yeah
sorry Council new Council the new
any further apologies
sorry
counselor sorry is
on his way probably from work I imagine
thank you very much
um finally any other before we do move
to the first item the next item on the
agenda the agenda item is the first
business of the meeting is the election
of the mayor and councilor Acton will
move the motion
thank you councilor Acton
thank you Mr Mayor it's with great
pleasure and a real honor to be able to
move my colleague and friend Dolores
O'Sullivan to be our mayor for the new
Municipal year
as some of you know Dolores is a proud
Irish woman
and was the youngest probably people
wouldn't know was the youngest of eight
children in her family
she was brought up in Kerry
on a farm in a small close-knit
community
and through good and bad times the
community supported each other and that
was a really important thing for Dolores
clearly her home upbringing shaped her
deep commitment of community and looking
out for each other and making sure the
well-being of the neighborhood was
looked after
Dolores moved to England at the age of
20 and lived in Old Trafford I don't
know where that is but
she she joined
other members of her family her family
ran a business in Manchester where
devorah started as a telephonist and
over time worked her way up to the top
doing all sorts of different jobs in
between
I suppose the youngest of eight children
you have to have a strong character to
work your way up
anyway I I did ask Dolores what have you
done to relax we're not working
and she said
I love dancing
and was quite good at it
so I said well
would you like to apply to be on
Strictly when when she finishes her
mayoral year
not lightly she said strictly junk
judges and the public are not ready for
my kind of dancing
and I would actually love you to
demonstrate it
she also had to go at her flying lessons
now I don't know how that went but I
hope the flying was better than the
driving
but but flying is is probably it
probably summed up Dolores the way that
she has lived her life she's a high
flyer she sometimes hits turbulence and
occasionally has crashed Landings but
nothing seems to phase her
as she learned in her younger days she
believes in the power of community and
the importance of working together to
create a brighter future for all and I
would say Dolores has a strong record of
service and Leadership and I have no
doubt that she will bring that same
dedication and hard work to the role as
mayor she's a fierce advocate for the
needs of our community and she will be
tireless in ensuring that voices of all
our communities are heard she really
believes in that finally I have no doubt
that Dolores under Dolores term of
office
Trafford will continue to thrive and
flourish I therefore ask members to
support councilor old Sullivan to be our
next mayor thank you very much
thank you councilor Acton is the motion
seconded
yes Mr Mayor thank you
um
a conservative group of Trafford are
pleased to Second uh councilor Dolores
O'Sullivan on becoming or to become
mayor of Trafford
having personally been very active in
Chris Boise's fundraising activities in
his mayoral year I now grasp the hours
of commitment required someone to say
such an important role
I won't dwell on the joys of collecting
on Ultraman High Street with a QR code
and a yellow bucket in hand
and I think that Chris must have been
called upon to do more ceremonial duties
than the mayor for many years with the
passing of her majesty a proclamation a
by-election instructor nursing finishing
on a high with uplifting coronation
Dolores you may have your work cut out
if this continues
Dolores you have done so much work with
the community groups in Trafford that
the role of Mayor of Trafford should
come easily to you you will no doubt be
as good at the roles as you have been as
popular and hard-working Community
focused counselor
I took the time earlier to message
Andrew Weston for a few tidbits about
you and he came back with a response
that I considered to be wonderful
Accolade and he said among other things
that Dolores is great at she always she
is always a fantastic supporter of our
older residents taking time to visit
them regularly a common theme here there
was also a comment about driving I think
I'll leave that one out
and and unfortunately for us Dolores is
an enthusiastic canvasser well tonight
Dolores you'll have our vote
um so may you and the Merrell consort
John Smith have a wonderful year and
please count the conservative support
with your community work fundraising and
events and we're very happy to Second
Dolores from that thank you
[Applause]
thank you councilor Evans is the motion
supported
yes Mr Matt it's a privilege to be able
to offer the support of the liberal
Democrat group to councilor Dolores
O'Sullivan as she receives the
nomination for our mayor this year and I
want to start my contribution just by
restating counselor brophy's apologies
because it's me on my feet this evening
but this is very much Jane's tribute to
you
um because
I know as our most experienced and
longest serving liberal Democrat
counselor she's deeply disappointed that
she cannot be here herself this evening
especially as she supported you last
year to become deputy
picture the scene it's spring 2014 the
Intrepid councilor Jane Brophy is
pounding the streets of Trafford
collecting nomination signatures for the
liberal Democrat candidates in the
forthcoming local elections as she
approaches one house she knocks on the
door and starts the usual putter my name
is councilor Jane Brophy I'm from
Trafford liberal Democrats I'm just
wondering would you be so kind as to
support our the nomination of our
candidate this year
but then the reply comes no I don't
think so Jane I'm actually the labor
counselor
councilor Brophy looks up from the
bright yellow clipboard to find
councilor Dolores O'Sullivan looking
kindly back at her
counselor Sullivan you offered a very
polite no thank you to the liberal
Democrat on your doorstep that day but
perhaps other members may have been more
direct
nevertheless we thank you for your mercy
on that occasion and we know we will
have no need to call on it again whilst
you're in the chair
the role of the mayor is not just to
chair Council meetings though it is to
be an ambassador for Trafford and
councilor Sullivan you are supremely
qualified for that role as a veteran
School governor with 20 years experience
serving three of our excellent schools
you're also someone who Champions mental
health and well-being having worked with
mind and other mental health charities
you're an experienced counselor in the
other sense of the word supporting
people with their mental health and this
is something that our society needs more
of and it's reflected throughout your
record of Public Service
councilor Sullivan has chosen two
Charities to support this year the first
the little green sock project is a
wonderful trafford-based charity and
with a third of children in Greater
Manchester living in poverty some 11 000
of them here in Trafford the project
aims to ease the financial burden that
faces too many families in arborough by
reusing and gifting in children's
clothing little green sock really are
making a positive impact in people's
lives
providing clothing which is a basic need
but helping the environment to by
cutting down on waste
the second charity modern marriage
chosen is Doctors Without Borders and we
see the need of their excellent work in
our news feeds every day
and not just because of the war in
Ukraine but because of the 71 other
countries that Doctors Without Borders
offer support to because of the
thousands of pregnant women supported in
Yemen the tens of thousands of vaccines
provided in Syria the Congolese children
supported with food and with medicine
these are excellent charities
so congratulations to you on this proud
day and the liberal Democrats wish you
all the very best in your year as I'm
there we are proud to support your
nomination
[Applause]
thank you councilor is the motion
further supported
thanks chair the green party also is
more than happy to support councilor
Doris O'Sullivan in her year as mayor
over the next year
um Dolores was elected in in 2010 and
served on the councils since that time
Dolores will have seen lots of
cost-cutting reshaping of lots of and
lots of changes in that time but Dolores
will be great in a great position to
understand and celebrate the residents
of this Borough over the next year
hailing from County Kerry
Dolores May recognize this Irish motto
and I've had some training from
Geraldine so I'm going to give it a go
um call Kawa cordius which translates
into English to cooperation help and
friendship
these are principles that will serve our
new mayor well not only in this chamber
but also when out meeting the many
communities and peoples across Trafford
it was it was when Dolores was 20 that
she set sail on the wild Atlantic waves
and landed on these Shores
but Dolores has carved out a
professional career in construction and
Engineering working in the public and
private sector in the council she has
played a strategic role in the Stratford
Town partnership which will hopefully
see its transformation over the coming
years
Dolores
has chosen Charities for her mayoral
year in particular little green sub
project a charity that recycles reuses
and gives clothing and toys to the local
communities and to those that may be
struggling to afford them it also is a
champion of the circular economy as we
are too so we're really glad that you've
chosen that local Trafford charity
um and Dolores would also
be supporting medicine Sean Frontier
providing medical help to people around
the world that most need it
Dolores is also joined by consort Joan
Smith who has survived cancer but used
it as a platform to help others through
Community engagement and charity events
we'd also love to see the mobile disco
making an appearance in alteringham
which is used to fundraise across the
borough and I'm sure even councilor
welcome will get his guitar out and join
join forces
but the the green party just wanted to
welcome you both to your new roles to
wish you every success and we will
endeavor to support whenever we can
thank you chair
[Applause]
thank you councilor Jerome
the motion is that councilor Dolores
O'Sullivan be and is hereby elected
mayor of the borough of Trafford for the
forthcoming Municipal Year all those in
favor
[Applause]
we will now retire for our new mayor to
be dressed in the mail robes and chains
of office
foreign
father fellow members ladies and
gentlemen good evening and thank you for
sharing this special evening with me
where to start
it becomes no surprise when I tell you I
was born in Ireland
the name and the slight accent may have
already given it away
I was born near the beautiful lakes of
Killarney in a town called Kenmare
I came from a family of eight children
our family were self-sufficient as
butchers Bakers and fish from the local
River
there was little waste in our home
surplus food was pickled and preserved
as there was no fridges in those days
this was where my education began
I learned to work hard play my part and
waste nothing
I also learned to share and care for
others
many Travelers came to our door and were
never sent away hungry
we were not extravagant
in fact I remember my brother Bernie
getting into trouble for bringing two
salmon home from fishing when we only
needed one
we shared with our neighbors and they
shared with us
that there was a great sense of
community spirit
this indeed left me with a lasting
impression
and probably on reflection it set my
political path
for this I thank my parents especially
my mother
who was a great cook mender and maker
and source of information inspiration to
me
I would like to thank my parents are
looking down at me tonight and feeling
just as proud as I am
my brother Bernie was first across the
water to England
and over the years a number of my
siblings followed
including my parents
and myself at the rightful old age of
20.
as we've been taught to share and look
after each other
my brother kindly shared his office work
with me
and this
and this continued until he solds the
business in 2005.
Trafford became my first home and has
been for most of my adult life
Trafford like Ken mayor has given me so
much
my children were educated here and they
in turn gave me three beautiful
grandchildren
the people of Stratford gave me my first
chance to serve as a counselor when they
elected me in 2010.
due to boundary changes I now live in
flixton ward
and I'm very grateful to the people who
supported me as the counselor for the
second time
I've also been proud to serve in the
community as a registrar at our local
Parish Church
and also as a governor at Our Lady of
the Rosary ermson Junior school and sin
Margaret Ward
there is so much I have been given
already by so many
all whom I need to thank
the support of Chris boys our outgoing
mayor who has been brilliant
father Karen Malarkey of Saint John
Henry Newman Parish who was agreed to be
my chaplain
Natalie Michelle and Matthew
and officers for their support so far
and I hope they will continue to help
the in the coming year
my thanks to the group leaders for the
kind words and support of me tonight
also and the Western MP and my own group
who've given me the chance to serve as
mayor for the coming year
would last there were no means lease
Jill my consort
for the help and support she has done
I would like to mention my Charities
which are little green sock
Trafford domestic abuse and Doctors
Without Borders
which I hope you will agree our great
Charities and worthy of our support
as you can imagine for me this year will
be like no other
it is an immense honor
I am so looking forward to meeting many
Community groups and businesses that
make Trafford one of the best boroughs
in the country
meeting the amazing volunteers of the
friends groups that make Trafford A
Greener cleaner Borough and the many
many people who Care and Share their
time and help to improve this amazing
Borough
Madam Deputy Mayor and consort
I hope you have an enjoyable year
and if I can be of any help as Chris has
helped me it would be my pleasure
as JFK said ask not what your country
can do for you but what you can do for
your country
I will do my best to film them fulfill
my role as mayor of Trafford thank you
[Applause]
the next item of business is the
appointment of the deputy mayor
councilor Amy White
counselor was removed the motion
and may I be the first to congratulate
you and welcome you to your much
deserved role as has become accustomed
to me I hope you find it as every bit as
fulfilling as enriching as my mayoral
year was a few years ago I know you will
do the borough proud and it is with
great pleasure that I propose the motion
that councilor Amy white be appointed as
our deputy mayor for the municipal year
ahead and I look forward to saying maybe
a little bit more in 12 months time
is the motions
congratulations to yourself again and
we're as a conservative group happy to
second the motion
is the motion supported by the green
party
thank you chair the the green party
fully supports
councilor white
Deputy Mayor thank you
foreign
party
it is
thank you
the motion is to counsel Amy white be
and hereby appointed deputy mayor
of the borough of Trafford for the
ensuing Municipal year
please would counselor all those
favorites
please with councilor white come up to
receive the chain and Badge of office
thank you
foreign
I wish to announce that Mrs Jones Smith
will act as my concert for this year
the returning mirrors will now invest my
concert with the chain and batch of
office
foreign
I now invite the deputy mayor to appoint
her Deputy Council today for the ensuing
year
I wish to announce that Sarah hooks will
act as my Deputy consult during the
incident year
I now call on councilman to move a vote
of thanks to the retiring mayor Ameris
may I too congratulate you on taking up
your new position
now though it gives me great pleasure to
propose the vote of thanks to outgoing
mayor my friend Chris boys
a year ago in this chamber seeing Chris
enrobed in Merrill regalia gave the firm
impression that he was a person very
much suited to being the mayor the first
citizen of our Borough
and he has proved that first impression
through the year every day that he's
been our mayor
that day few of us could have envisaged
that the mayoral year would be quite so
dramatic and even historic
so we thank Chris very much indeed
For What followed because fate delivered
into the his capable hands
the role of being mayor at a time of the
passing of the monarch
for the first time in trafford's history
trafford's mayor proclaimed from the
steps of the Town Hall the accession of
a new monarch
carrying on the method used over
centuries to spread the word of such
news
and we all admire it the way that Chris
carried that off that day
much is to this delight I'm sure Chris
boys was soon to meet King Charles III
in person
what greater honor Can America have than
to welcome
the Monarch to Trafford Borough
well perhaps a greater honor personally
for Chris maybe that he was named in the
court circular covering that visit
he is recorded for posterity with these
words from the Palaces Court circular
the king afterwards visited Kellogg's
Factory Trafford Park to Mark the
company's Centenary in the United
Kingdom
and was received by the managing
director the plant director and the
mayor of Trafford Mr Chris Boyce
that alone must be so rewarding for you
Chris
was busy of course he is always a busy
man those of us who know him know that
you have to work hard to pin him down
his engagements as mayor included a
moving service of dedication
for the garden
for grieving parents
where those people can now go to
remember loved ones
he attended a memorial service for the
falling of the Falcons was war sorry
he was present for the unveiling of a
memorial to a Bomber Crew lost just down
the road from here at Walton Park
and very much an issue of our times
there was also an event
which was a welcoming of citizens of
Ukraine coming to Trafford
to safety to be hosted by Trafford
residents
the Trafford International women's day
Awards event was opened by Chris as
mayor
indeed he was pleased and happy to
appear where Trafford residents asked
him to appear and we thank him for all
of that wonderful work
I won't try to list more of the
engagements of which there were so many
but looking at a list we do get to know
the caliber of them and the importance
of them to Trafford and its residents
so much goodness so much kindness
so much thoughtfulness
of course every mayor raises money for
charity
but I get the impression that Chris
pushed harder with that aim than than
most
I don't know how much he raised I think
they're still counting I'm sure it's a
significant sum
but there will be some good causes
happily sending thank you letters to him
and for that we thank him too
by his side Chris's wife Pam fulfilled
the role of mayores with the aplomb we
would anticipate from this double Act
and the council sincere thanks go to her
too
I genuinely hope Chris and Pam enjoyed
their spec Tech spectacular year I'm
absolutely certain they did
and I'm certain too that it's a year
that local historians will be recording
for a great many reasons
so thank you Chris thank you Pam
sit back now and relax
Madame mayor I have great pleasure in
proposing this vote of thanks
is the vote seconded
yes Madam my pleasure to rise on behalf
of the labor group to support the Vault
of thanks and I'll be under remiss if I
didn't congratulate you on your your
appointment
General feedback we're getting yeah uh
Chris and Palmer have been outstanding
mayor Ramirez throughout the Earth we're
used to be our mayor's actually being
very good though casting my mind back
over 50 years the hobby one or two that
I've exempt from that but not recently
but I'm going to pass the history of one
or two people but uh Palmer and Chris
and Palmer really being exceptional
chemical weapons outline some of the
major
is that working yes
I've outlined some of the major events
for the momentous events including the
coronation and the the Declaration but
also the most smaller events where
they've been very assiduous in attending
throughout the year and I know it's you
know it's quite a serious and
time-consuming job at being there no
it's not a light under undertaking
but if I could just speak for from a
personal point of view uh the mayor and
the merits were very keen to attend
various events during sale Festival
which is in June and tickets are
available for this year's performance
but uh but they were very keen to attend
and I didn't know before that but the
mayor's a very big fan of Dolly Parton
uh I'm not sure she's a fan of him but
uh she's a big fan of Dolly Parton and
we had uh in last year we had a Dolly
Parton tribute Act and the mayor is very
keen to come along unfortunately the
Dolly Parton tribute act stuck to
closely to Dolly's song nine till five
and because this was at eight o'clock
she forgot and didn't turn up so so the
mayor was he was there in Olney regalia
and the chair of the festival committee
was rather embarrassed but they met put
him at ease really and some of us who
stayed in the bar at quite a good time
actually despite the non-appearance of
Dolly Parton but uh
the the mouse uh really if I could just
uh mention another of Dolly's song
really is that well I'll mentioned first
that obviously the mayor is going to be
uh have more time on his hands let's say
uh it's the elephants in the room is it
going to have more time on his hands
than he had previously but he's a very
very expert and Keen photographer I'm
sure he'll be you know anxious to carry
that and he also he plays golf I'm not
quite sure how expertly he plays golf
but he'll have more time to play in golf
and after all those events I'm sure we
keep an eye on uh Pam to find him
something else to do if he gets bored
because of plenty of things to do now
but so just to close uh Mr Madame mayor
that I just one of other dollies songs
not Lester North it's a it's a sort of
uh him I think it's uh when the role is
Called Up Yonder you'll be there now in
this case Yonder I mean on the walls
outside here you'll be there on the list
of of mayors of America
so we do thank you
um
councilor boys or Mr boys and Pam for
your service during the last 12 months I
know it's never easy being the mayor and
it's never easy I think it comes a
little bit when hinted you're at one
event where somebody said to me he looks
like the mayor
and I think that that's true really so
congratulations for all your work during
the year and have a good retirement
thank you
[Applause]
is the Vault supported
the vote is supported madam would I have
a chance to speak
yes thank you madam for the opportunity
to express the liberal Democrats thanks
and appreciation of Chris and Pam's time
in office a notable busy year as the
first citizen of Trafford attending
impressive 260 official engagements
across the borough greater Manchester
and further afield
representing us while supporting the
diverse communities of Trafford notably
amongst all of these and one that had a
deep historic meaning for us all was the
accession proclamation in the in his
town hall of steps of Trafford one that
I felt very honored to attend and
Witness
personally I would like to extend thanks
to former mayor boys for his attend his
attendance at Ultraman Festival the
largest free show in Trafford and
timpley Country Fair also both of which
were warmly welcome and enjoyed by our
residents
you can't fail to mention in these
thanks the work three worthy Charities
that have benefited from his
considerable fundraising activities
namely Parkinson's UK the Royal children
hospital and the children's air
ambulance laudable beneficiaries one and
all
perhaps I can add my personal admiration
to the former counselor that possibly
seeing that way that his time of office
was coming to an end made that last
email it was all raising unfinished
safety improvements to Norris Road the
mark of a dedicated counselor serving
his community every step of the way
I mean we wish Chris and Pam well in all
the future endeavors and hope that that
now you have time for to afford those
and enjoy them thank you
is the book supported by the
conservative party
right is the vote supported by the green
party
thank you
yeah we're delighted to um support the
motion of thanks
um the green party just wanted to say a
big thank you to you to you for your
great efforts as mayor this year
um and also to the support you've had
from Pam too you've done an incredible
job in terms of raising the profile and
raising money for your chosen Charities
only wish I could have attended more of
those events
I've also been impressed by the manner
in which you've conducted business in
the chamber reaching out to group
leaders trying to streamline debate and
successfully moving um on items with
within the given time not an easy feat
at all but you've done it with style and
a plum
I'd also like to say a big thank you to
you from the green party we have enjoyed
your hospitality at full Council
meetings
um after afterwards a chance to get to
know fellow counselors and continue to
debates in a more friendly and convivial
setting with your hospitality showing
through so we just wanted to say Well
done and good luck for the future to
both you and Pam thanks chair
I can't
thank you
the most is the council hereby place on
record their appreciation for the matter
in which Mr Chris Boyz has carried out
his duties
as mayor of the borough of Trafford
during his period of office the terror
and to him and his best wishes took in
that connection they also expressed
their gratitude to Mrs Pamela boys
for the manner in which she has acted as
mayores
all those in favor
Louisiana
bear with us for a moment
foreign
concert to present the retirement race
with the replica of Badge of office
I now call upon the retiring mayor Mr
Chris Boyce to respond
thank you madam mayor um I've viewed
last year's video of the annual Council
and noted that in fact Council wall sat
down but I intend to stand to to make
this presentation
so here we are again in time for another
of my lists and just as last year to
begin with there are many thank yous
first to those who have spoken such kind
words about myself and the mayores who I
can assure you have thoroughly enjoyed
the opportunity to serve this wonderful
Borough
then thanks to every single council
member and officer for the totally
courteous manner in which the mayor s
and I have been received and the help
which which they have been so willing to
give us
to everyone in the community especially
those who work tirelessly as volunteers
those who have greeted us whenever and
wherever we have visited and of course
to the Mayors mayor S's and consorts the
Chain Gang of the other nine boroughs in
Greater Manchester and of course are
four during the year MPS
every year of Our Lives is unique as is
every mayoral year however I would
suggest there will never be another
quite like ours
over 275 engagements plus another 35
which for various reasons we were unable
to fulfill and these were often
undertaken by the deputy mayor
those visits included around 30 with
school pupils 10 with the uniformed
organizations around 20 visits to Care
Homes and close to 60 engagements which
involved music of every possible genre
the mayoral handbook encourages support
for events representing the ethnic
diversity of the borough and Hindu
festivals Chinese celebrations and
afro-caribbean events produce some of
the most colorful and joyous scenes I
have ever witnessed
my appeal for worthy residents to be
invited to the Civic reception produce
representatives from a widespread of
community supporting organizations and
we were able to treat them to treat them
to by far the best meal of the Year
easily surpassing that of any of the
other boroughs
we all knew there was to be a platinum
Jubilee and the beacon lighting ceremony
in Partington was early in the calendar
who could have foretold what was to
follow
the passing of Queen Elizabeth brought
about ceremonies which had not been seen
in the whole history of the borough
proclamations in Manchester and at
Trafford town hall and Memorial Services
both at the Cathedral and at Saint
Paul's in sale all arranged at little
more than a couple of days notice
meanwhile normal duties continued
including some truly meaningful events
in the form of citizenship Ceremonies
for whom those taking part are the
culmination of a lengthy process by
which they gain British nationality
it is not every mayor who acts as a
parliamentary election returning officer
however a resignation in GM cascaded
down to mean there was a in December a
parliamentary by-election which saw our
Council leader whisked away to
Westminster
it is also not every mayor who has the
privilege of welcoming a royal visitor
so in January the coded email
rvkc raw visit King Charles provided the
highlight of the year in the form of the
visit to Kellogg's of the king somebody
that I have always wished to meet
especially as he is in my school year or
vice versa then another coded email in
March rvpr meant that it was down to me
to greet the Princess Royal on her visit
to Coronation Street and finally just
like those queuing buses came a message
that the Duchess of Edinburgh was to
visit Holly Saint Peters three Royal
visits and still a coronation to come
with the borough offering a celebration
event at sail Waterside
oh and we work with two separate Lord
lieutenants and numerous deputies in
addition to the normal two high sheriffs
and of course the GM mayor Andy Burnham
my Charities have benefited from the
support of my charity committee who
arranged the Lord Digby Jones luncheon
the sports dinner with Sammy McElroy a
fabulous fashion evening a St George's
night and most recently a dinner at
Trafford College's Aspire restaurant
I know the Trafford branch of
Parkinson's UK the Royal Manchester
children's hospital and the children's
air ambulance are immensely grateful for
the support we have been able to give
them
I must also thank my chaplains both rev
and Johnny Hill and Reverend Richard
Sherritt not only for words at Council
but also for leading the celebration of
Christmas at St John's and the Civic
Sunday at Ashton on mersey United
Reformed Church
all in all a quite remarkable
Unforgettable year
but for once as predicted last May made
even more enjoyable by Natalie's admin
support and Matthew's unstinting skills
at both navigation and punctuality
in closing may I take this opportunity
on behalf of Pam and myself to wish our
mayor and her consort all the very best
for what we hope will for them also be a
truly memorable year thank you
[Applause]
thank you Mr boys
that then concludes the insulation part
of the meeting
if they now prefer I will ask the deputy
consort consort my chaplain and our
guest to retire to the committee room
five while we proceed with the business
part of the meeting
please could I ask members to take their
seats
thank you all for your patience so far
and we now continue with the business
part of the meeting
item four
the next item minutes I will move that
the minutes of the meeting held on the
20th the 23rd of March 2022 you read be
taken as read and signed as a correct
record
you start seconded
seconded math
all those in favor
item five election results
noting the results for the recent
election mayor welcome councilor Babar
or um Baskerville
chakravarti Deacon ecclesley Hearst
liporee Parker Paul Spencer Sutton and
Taylor
for their first council meeting
and welcome back Michael my Cordon Lee
and Nathan Evans who rejoins Us in the
chamber
congratulations to you all and and all
the members who were successfully
reelected
the terms of office for everyone elected
are set out in the report and I asked
the council to note this
item six
firstly the council is requested to
appoint a leader of the council and I'm
aware that nomination for councilor Tom
Ross is at second place
thank you mayor um and I would like to
Second this proposal and before I do I'd
like to add my congratulations to you
um I am delighted to see you in the role
and I think you will make a fantastic
mayor
um I'm also delighted to Second
councilor Tom Ross as leader of the
council and I think his record in public
office and his leadership of the council
to date
um have demonstrated that he has a real
commitment to the people of Trafford and
particularly our most vulnerable
residents our children and young people
um and I think Tom Ross will continue to
lead the borough with the utmost
integrity and my second emotion thank
you Matt
thank you
may I ask Council Ross nominated
nomination is approved by the council
I am
thank you councilor Tom Ross is
appointed leader of the council until
the expiry of his term of office as
counselor in 2023
I now turn to the leader of the council
and invite councilor Ross to appoint his
deputy and members of his executive
thank you mayor I am delighted that
councilor Kath Hines is continuing as
Deputy leader of the council we can ask
for no better deputy and no better
support to me than cath particularly
over my first few months as leader of
this Borough I'm also delighted to
announce my new executive for the
municipal year and I'd ask that
colleagues note the names of the
executive and also the reshaped
portfolios for the executive which
reflect our priorities as an
Administration for the year ahead thank
you
together
thank you the council is asked to note
the executive appointments and the
membership of the Shadow executive that
has also been circulated around the
chamber
can they be noted please
item seven
is the appointment of the council
committee and I invite the leader of the
council to move the recommendations for
the purpose for the proposed committee
structure and the membership of the
2023-2024 municipal year
thank you Matt I'm happy to move
recommendations one to eight as set out
in the paper
is that seconded
it says seconded thank you
thank you the motion has been moved and
seconded is that agreed
item eight
may I ask the leader to move that the
outside body nominations made by the
council be agreed are set out in the
report schedule and for him to appoint
those bodies which relate to the
executive functions
can I have a second of please for the
council appointments right right sorry
go ahead thank you Matt I'm happy to
move recommendations one to four in the
report
can I have a
have a sec Council appointments
um yes that's seconded thank you mayor
all those in favor
thank you
item nine
next on the agenda item 9 and the
council is requested to agree that the
calendar of the council and committee
meetings for 2022 sorry 20 23 24.
I now ask the leader of the council to
move this item
thank you mayor I'm happy to move the
committee timetable for the year ahead
is that seconded please
um yes and I am happy to second that
thank you mayor thank you
item 10 delegation in an urged action
please can ask the council to approve
the committee arrangements for dealing
with the delegate decision and the
Urgent action set out on the Council of
someone says
is that a Creed
thank you
item 11. delegation of functions and
amendments to the Constitution
council is asked to confirm the
arrangements for the delegation of
council and executive functions and to
consider alterations at the Constitution
following the annual review by the
monitoring officer
please can the leader of the council
move that the executive and officer
scheme of Delegation be confirmed as set
out in the report
thank you mayor I'm happy to move
recommendations one to four in the
report
is that seconded
yes it is thank you mayor
the motion has been moved and seconded
is that agreed
thank you
item 12.
the next report this evening
details the executive key decisions over
the past year which were taken under the
special urgency provisions and is for
the council to note
can I ask therefore for this to be noted
thank you
item 13.
please can I ask the leader of the
council to move the proposal set out and
Report regarding the protocol to be
followed before and at the council
meetings with amendments to a motion is
proposed
thank you mayor I am happy to move the
uh Amendment sorry the the proposals in
this report
is that second of please
yes it is thank you um
does any members wish to speak on this
report
Council wishing to speak
the report has been moved and seconded
can it be agreed please
thank you
item 14 members allowances the
finalizable concerns recommendations of
the independent real relation panel for
the level of allowances made
to members paid members please can the
lead of the council introduce this
matter
and propose abortion for the council to
determine councilor
thank you mayor returning members will
recall that earlier this calendar year
an independent remuneration panel was
convened to look at our current
allowances scheme and review it
the independent remuneration panel was
made up of three people including one
connected to Trafford college and one
local resident their details are set out
in the report the IRP had cross-party
representations
again set out in the report and also
received feedback from Council officers
the IRP compared our existing scheme
with other schemes in Greater Manchester
and the IRP as a result of that provided
a series of recommendations to bring our
scheme more in line with other schemes
across operating across greater
Manchester which I welcome
the report asks the council to consider
recommendations one to three in the
report I am happy to remove this report
thank you Matt thank you
is that seconded please
um yes it is seconded thank you mayor um
I am happy to Second this report which I
do think contains some sensible and
reasoned recommendations for us to
consider this evening as councilor Ross
has said this will bring trafford's
allowances closer to those of other GM
um local authorities and although we
will still be the lowest in GM and for
over a decade trafford's basic
allowances have barely increased
um and whilst there are some reasons for
this it has meant that we are now some
considerable distance from GM councils
and I know that council is in Trafford
do carry out this role we all carry out
this role to serve the people of the
borough and so it is important that our
allowances do enable us to do that
effectively and I also think it is
important that the council itself does
reflect the diversity of the people that
it represents and that it doesn't become
only for people who are financially able
to do so so I'm happy to um second this
proposal thank you Matt
thank you
does any members wish to speak on this
report
no
so we've got two speakers is that
correct
um
and
I'm sorry
uh right can I ask councilman pleased to
speak
thank you it's your own thank you
uh first of all we would like to thank
the panel for producing this report an
independent panel made up of the Ponte
appointees with a range of skills and
experience from outside of this Council
equalities and the implications are at
the heart of this proposed proposal in
the report it says it encourages persons
from all sections of the community to
become and remain counselors something
we fully support
it is important to remember how this
report was arrived at from members of
use
by Consulting the relevant Council
offices by comparison with the other
10gm councils but also with the broader
Financial picture in mind
this report and the green party
understand the current cost of living
crisis and the tough choices people are
facing however this also reminds us that
we need good politicians and voices from
all walks of life
we must also remember the very low base
of the Trafford allowance
this report recognizes that the Trafford
allowance is far lower than other GM
councils it recognizes this scheme
hasn't been reviewed for 20 years and
the roles and demands of this role have
changed too in fact they've grown
the basic allowance will rise to just
over ten thousand which brings us nearer
to our GM equivalents but still
considerably behind most of them the
report also mentions the voluntary
discount that means 35 of
the councilors time nearly 46 days a
year are still unpaid and voluntary
we did find that we had some questions
or some negatives about the report
um the leaders of the minority
opposition groups will only receive a
special remuneration allowance if the
group is at least four members rather
than the current two we would question
that but also understand that this is an
independent review
paragraph 153 on the report sets out the
arguments for this but there doesn't
seem to be any evidence or reasoning
given here from our experience the
working in establishing a small party is
immense and when covid struck all group
leaders were pulled together behind the
leadership to help steer this Council in
weekly meetings maybe this is something
the review could consider in four years
time
but the conclusion from us from the
green party I think overall is we fully
support this report we recognize there
are some things we don't entirely agree
with however as a small party we know it
is challenging to encourage and enable
diversity many look at politics and
don't see themselves and think it is not
for them remuneration is just one
barrier but an important one this is a
step in the right direction thank you
Jeff
thank you
uh councilor Evans please
thank you madam mayor
um firstly we must thank the independent
panel for their time on this matter it
can't be easy and they've arrived at a a
report however the conservative
councilors are questioning the timing of
this report from the labor run
Administration choosing to wait until
after the local elections to Pro propose
what is a huge increase in Council
allowances
one wonders if labor felt it wouldn't go
down too well on the doorsteps did they
feel a 40 hike in counselor allowances
wasn't a vote winner with the residents
of Trafford
can Services think Labor's timing says
it all it's ironic that labor campaigned
in the local elections on their concern
for the cost of living crisis and our
former leader secured a debate in
Parliament this week on the same topic
yeah the very first thing this labor
Administration does to repeat a phrase
used before is trouser a little bit more
cash
although my group acknowledges that the
councilor's allowances have not
increased for years the conservatives
are not in the role for the money
however an important item does come out
of this report
and that we do welcome it is recognized
by the independent body
that Trafford holds its meetings in the
evenings enabling counselors to be able
to work full-time we therefore ask that
this is recognized in all our suggested
meeting times by the council officers
and labor moving forward we have many
new councilors all of whom work all who
will appreciate not being pressured into
daytime meetings
a counselor's basic allowance rise of 40
is a matter for Labor's conscience and
one given the timing and the contrived
way this seems to arrived at the AGM we
won't be supporting this thank you madam
thank you
Council of France please
thank you mayor
our understanding was that this report
has been commissioned to provide an
independent view of how remuneration
Stacks up against the other local
authorities in the region it's very easy
for those of us comfortably off to say
that we're not here for the money but
that attitude completely ignores the
fact that many in our Borough cannot
afford to be democratically elected
local representatives for their
communities from a progressive Viewpoint
those who are lucky enough to get to the
front
ought to use that privilege and that
advantage to help those behind them
bringing the basic allowance closer to
the greater Manchester average as we've
heard alluded to tonight will I hope
enable a greater more diverse range of
people to represent their area in this
chamber
however I am struggling to understand
the rationale that's already been
alluded to my colleagues in the green
party behind .153 on page 142 in the
report agenda pack
the size of all of our groups goes up
and down as is Right In a Democracy it
just so happens that during the covid
pandemic my group comprised three
councilors this is below the new
threshold of four proposing the report
meaning that our leader would receive no
remuneration at all to allow them to
take on the additional responsibilities
such as
you might hear during covid all the
opposition group leaders were heavily
involved in the council's
decision-making processes and used their
positions to make the case that they
thought were important to the voters
that elected them
our group leader was there time after
time making the case for things which
had a real and tangible impact to help
stop that wretched virus back in 2020
pushing for amongst other things covid
testing before discharge from hospital
into Care Homes he was making the case
for getting a vaccine Center in the Lark
Hill Center because we didn't have one
and the idea that our group to quote the
report would not have the same
pressure to provide primary challenge
as a group of three as opposed to four
or six is wrong
so there's no justification given in the
report for this change that Trafford
should suddenly require fall rather than
two other than let us double two
so the lib Dems therefore would be
looking to see if that could be amended
thank you
could counselor Thomas please
can I congratulate you as a ward
colleague on your Ascension to the mayor
tonight uh just briefly to say that I I
took part in this uh review I was
interviewed by the independent
very independent board
and on hunted honestly what's coming
back is what they recommend
we've taken or I certainly will be
taking up by a recommendation because I
think it's fair I think it opens up
opportunities for others that are on low
income perhaps not people that can
squirrel away into leafy suburbs to get
reelected
thank you
councilor Ross like to respond
thank you mayor can I just first thank
um councilor Girona and also the Council
of France and liberal Democrat groups
for group for their comments this
evening
um absolutely your feedback is is is is
is is very valid I think as I've said to
you in separate uh in separate
correspondence it was our position as a
group that we accept the independent
recommendations that have been made by
the the panel but of course as Council
Jerome has noted there will be future
panels and there'll be a future time
where we can review the scheme again and
I think it's important that we start to
observe what the independent
recommendations are because it is done
by people who are take a lot of evidence
in review it Benchmark us against other
boroughs and ensure that we try and make
this uh this Borough as diverse as
possible in terms of the representation
that we have on Trafford Council and
that is very much something that I want
to see
in terms of uh councilor Evans firstly
um welcome back councilor Evans
I see you've not changed much since you
were lost your election last year
um
in all seriousness though I think to
come back to this chamber and cast
dispersions about my integrity and my
group Integrity is out of order and a
really big big mistake to make so early
on in your return to this Council I can
say that I did not receive the report
until the 10th of May this this month
you see that the evening of the 10th of
May I got a draft report we then didn't
get the final report until it was
published for all of us to see via the
publication of the paper so I hope you
retract that insinuation that I have
been sat on this for weeks because
frankly I haven't and you should also
have had some form of Handover with your
predecessor and other people that took
part in the panel because they would
have told you the feedback they would
have given they would have told you the
feedback from the panel itself so you
would have been under no surprises as
you went into the campaign as to what
the discussions had been as part of that
panel process so I hope you reflect on
the insinuations that you've cast our
way because do you know what I am proud
to represent this Borough and I just
want us to spring goes back into line
with the rest of Greater Manchester when
I first started as a counselor in 2008
the the basic allowance was 6121 pounds
if that had gone up in real terms over
the last 15 years it would now be 10 503
pounds what is proposed in this report
is 10 076 pounds so we're still not up
to that area if we followed the real
terms over the course of the 15 years so
I'm very grateful to the uh to the other
contributions that have been made by
constructive people within the chamber
and I hope counselor Evans that you
reflect on what you've said and
genuinely believe that we're all here
for the best interest of the borough we
want to make sure that we Safeguard the
future of this Pura and make sure that
we have strong politicians coming into
this Council in the future and by
observing the independent remuneration
panel's findings we're a step further
that way thank you
thank you
deported
can it be agreed please
advice do we need to put it to the vote
can those people
um
yeah please all those in favor can can
you raise your hands please
thank you
all those against
thank you any abstentions
thank you
the report has been agreed
the abortion has been carried that
brings us to the end of the meeting
can I thank you for your attendance this
evening and invite the deputy mayor the
chief executive the monitoring officer
to join me in the mayor's parlor for
photographs thank you and I look forward
to seeing you all at the reception
afterwards thank you
foreign